اثر بعد عين هي الصوره في منزل الشهيد عبد
القادر القواسمي في الخليل الذي هدمته
قوات الاحتلال هذه الليله مع منزل الشهيد
نصر الله القواسم الذي فجرته على مرحلتين
دمار كبير لحق بالمنزل في عمليه عسكريه
استمرت لاكثر من سبع ساعات خلالها قوات
الاحتلال هدمت هذا المنزل بمعدات وجرافات
كبيره وفجرت منزل الشهيد نصر الله القواسم
على مرحلتين فيما بقي منزل الشهيد حسن
قفيشه قيد الانشاء حتى هذه اللحظه الشهيد
عبد القادر القواسمي ونصر الله القواسمي
وحسن قفيشه نفذوا عمليه اطلاق نار عند
حاجز النفق جنوبي القدس في الساد عشر من
نوفمبر الماضي في عمليه اسفرت عن مقتل
جندي اسرائيلي واصابه سبعه اخرين سياسه
الهدم المستمره والمتواصل منذ السابع من
اكتوبر طالت 23 منزلا حتى هذه اللحظه ضمن
اطار سياسه العقاب الجماع التي تتخذه قوات
الاحتلال بحق
الفلسطينيين منتصر نصارى الجزيره الخليل
جنوب الضفه الغربيه